president Trump getting aggressive with
his foreign policy tonight he's closing
the Palestine Liberation office here in
Washington as punishment for the group's
rejection of peace talks with Israel
he's also firing a shot across the bow
of the International Criminal Court the
ICC the announcements were made by the
president's national security advisor
this afternoon correspondent Jillian
Turner has specifics today on the eve of
September the 11th I want to deliver a
clear and unambiguous message on behalf
of the President of the United States
the Trump administration's got the ICC
in its crosshairs today the United
States will use any means necessary to
protect our citizens and those of our
allies from unjust prosecution by this
illegitimate court and Bolling's not
taking any prisoners
we will not cooperate with the ICC we
will let the ICC die on its own after
all for all intents and purposes the ICC
is already dead to us and he didn't stop
there showing the US isn't afraid to
flex more than one foreign policy muscle
at a time next up on Bolton's hit list
the Palestinian Liberation Organization
or PLO the Department of State will
announce the closure of the Palestine
Liberation Organization office here in
Washington DC the State Department
explained the decision a few hours ago
saying the PLO has quote condemned a
u.s. peace plan they have not yet seen
and refused to engage with the US
government with respect to peace efforts
fully making clear when it comes to the
israeli-palestinian conflict the Trump
administration is officially taking
sides the United States will always
stand with our friend and ally Israel
but the Palestinians are punching back
calling on the ICC to immediately open
an investigation into Israel saying
quote we reiterate that the rights of
the Palestinian people are not for sale
that we will not succumb to us threats
and bullying and that we will continue
our legitimate struggle for freedom
Bolton also had words of warning for the
ICC when it comes to the war in
Afghanistan threatening US sanctions
against ICC judges should they launch an
investigation into what they say may
war crimes committed by the American
military and Intel community in
Afghanistan though the US has never been
a member of the ICC and has always kept
the court at arm's length this would be
the first time in history America
imposed sanctions on court judges the
ICC prosecutor has requested to
investigate these Americans for alleged
detainee abuse an utterly unfounded
unjustifiable investigation Bolton's
going all in to protect American
soldiers who've served in the 17 year
long war in Afghanistan he also invoked
president Trump's first major foreign
affairs speech back in 2016 in which he
promised to put American the American
people's security above all else Bolton
said today the administration's renewing
its commitment to an America first
foreign policy Brett Jillian thank you